[موسيقى]
متخبي الشمس بغربال الدراما السوريه تمر
بتحديات
هذه التحديات مرده لعناصر كثيره انت تعلم
يا صديقي انه في التسعينات وحتى منتصف ال
2000 كانت الدراما السوريه تتبوا مكان
حقيقه في صداره الدراما العربيه
لكن بالحروب وكما يحدث في الحروب وكما
يحدث وكما يحدث دائما بالاصطفاف السياسي
كما يحدث في الحروب من تدمير للبنت تحتيه
من ظروف حرب الاخره بمعنى هناك اصبح مشكله
بغياب راس مال مغامر راس مال مثقف راس مال
يستطيع ان يغامر واضيف له حصار التسويق
الدراما السوريه وانت لما بتصنع منتج لا
تضمن تسويقه بالضروره لن تهتم كثيرا فيه
لانه هو لم يعد منتجا للتصدير وشروط
تصديره غير مضمون
وجهه الدراما السوريه بهذا المكان حي
الشديد واعتقد انها الان هي في مخاض حقيقي
ولابد من حل مشكلتها اذا
اذا فتحت السواق امام الدراما السوريه
لانه انت بتعرف يا صديقي نحن ما عندنا سوق
داخليه للدراما يعني لا نملك عدد كما مصر
الشقيقه عدد كبير من المحطات التلفزيونيه
فهذا المنتج اذا لم تفتح امامه افاق
التسويق هو لن يرى النور بالاخر انت تتحدث
عن صناعه ثم اذا لم يعاد ترتيب البناء
الخدميه والتحتيه وكل الشروط التي توفير
ارضيه حقيقيه لانتاج الدراما متفرده
ثم طبيعه المواضيع نحن رحلتنا مع الدراما
في مطلع التسعينات كنا دائما بنقول لماذا
استطاعت الدراما السوريه ان تنتزع لها
مكان مختلف حقيقه لانها تحركت في فضاءات
متنوعه بدا من اعاده الانتاج الادب
الروائي الى الاعمال الوطنيه والنظاليه
شعبنا خلال سنواته الى اعمال الاسره
والعائله ان كانت كوميديا الى الاعمال
التي تتناول بام المؤسسات الرسميه
[موسيقى]